on a appris que pierre laurent était
favorable donc c'est le patron du parti
d'une liste est favorable à la
candidature de jean luc mélenchon alors
doit on a peu parlé tout à l'heure
comme la formation vient de nous
parvenir est ce que vous pouvez
commenter cette information
écoutez moi je soutiens du pc évidemment
la candidature non enfin je ne sais pas
exactement ce qui a été dit et des
carrés m'enfin gens soutiendront n'a
jamais été opposé à la candidature de
jean-luc mélenchon et et
le parti communiste n'était pas engagée
dans la démarche des primaires de la
gauche ça me prend pas cette non ça me
surprend pas maintenant on verra comment
comment les discussions c'est en tout
cas ça n'obère pas l'avenir pour la
suite
après les primaires de la gauche et pour
la constitution d'un rassemblement qui
permettent d'avoir une gauche en bon
état à l'élection au retour des jo pour
une discussion avec les copains mais je
crois qu'il ya des nuits les discussions
sont pas closes n'y a pas vous savez on
n'est pas comme avec françois bayrou
du côté de la droite on n'est pas en
train de te dire on veut pas de jean luc
mélenchon c'est pas du tout d'accord
mais je suis en luc mélenchon et d'autre
les verts voilà les les radicaux c'est
comme ça que la gauche peut être forte
quand elle est unie dans sa diversité